primark has promised to make all of its
clothes using recycled or sustainably
sourced materials but are pledges like
this enough to fix the fast fashion
industry and isabel i'm coming back to
you because i know this is this is your
line of business so is a pledge like
this genuine or is it greenwashing how
do we know
i think anything like this should be
welcomed and i think that the
corporate sector have got a huge part to
play in trying to
reduce the impact of the
fashion industry however it is in it is
incredibly complex you've got the
resource you have the human rights
issues you have the pollution issues
around chemicals and supply chain
mapping is very very complex for every
single retailer
so i think that the government does need
to step in and try and put in some
producer responsibilities but of course
there's also a lot that we can do as
consumers and just last night i went to
a second-hand
september oxfam
swishing event where everyone bought
their own clothes that they didn't want
to wear anymore and everyone swapped
them it was really fun and we talked
about the fact that actually we didn't
have to spend a lot of money to get new
items whilst recycling others and you
can do this with friends family at work
and i would really
encourage everybody to think more about
shopping online
even oxfam online is such a brilliant
website now it's really it's really easy
to use let me bring in let me bring in
dame julia king here you were mentioning
they're wanting the government to
intervene more but and we're a
capitalist economy how far can the
government really be
intervening in these matters and do you
would you advocate something that's like
a fashion equivalent of a sugar tax on
this industry
well i'd i'd like to see more um work
going into
helping people to understand their
carbon footprint and the impact of
things like this we know that young
people are actually very interested in
and very worried about climate change um
and actually they can be part of the
change to the kind of slow fashion that
isabella was talking about so um the
ipcc and the climate change committee in
the uk have asked for more climate
education and we have a a new um
secretary of state for education in
nadim zahawi just recently been
announced and i think this is a real
challenge for him
is that we should make climate education
absolutely core to the education of
young people in the uk so that people
understand the impact of fast fashion
and so that they can think about whether
that's an appropriate thing for them to
do and actually so that the people who
work in the fast fashion industry can
put pressure on their the companies they
work in to think differently about this
to think about new business models um
different ways of providing us with with
fun and enjoyable clothes that have less
impact on the environment and it's been
good to see you know some of these um uh
some of these apps starting up where uh
people are being encouraged to um to
sell their second-hand clothes
and give them another life all right
really good to talk to you both tonight
such important issues isabella gornall
dame julia king thank you very much for
your time
you